تشييع جثمان وديع جورج وسوف في بيروت
الكشف عن موعد اول مباراه لرونالدو في
الدوري السعودي الاردني يفك لغز جريمه
وقعت قبل 35 عاما هذه الاخبار وغيرها
ننقلها لكم من قناه العربيه فاهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
على انغامي اغاني والده النجم الكبير جورج
وسوف شو يعني اليوم جثمان الراحل وديع
جورج وسوف كنيسه القديس نيكولا الروم في
الاشرفيه بيبيروت
قال ابن الاكبر لسلطان الطرب توفي اول امس
الجمعه بعد ازمه صحيه تعرض لها جراء
مضاعفات عمليه تصغير معده اجرها مؤخرا في
ماء سيواره في مسقط راسه بمنطقه كفرون
السوريه
في خبر اثلج صدور جميع جماهيره اعلن نادي
النصر السعودي عن موعد اولى مباريات النجم
البرتغالي كريستيانو رونالدو في الدوري
السعودي مسؤول في نادي النصر قال ان
رونالدو سيخوض اولى مبارياته بقميص النادي
في الثاني والعشرين من يناير الجاري
وبالتالي سيكون متاحا لخوض لقاء النصر على
ملعبه امام نادي الاتفاق ذلك بعد ان يلهي
اللاعب عقوبه الايقاف لمباراتين كان تعرض
لها في نادي السابق مانشستر يونايتد
الى الاردن حيثمكن جهاز الامن العام من فك
لغز الجريمه وقعت قبل 35 عاما ضحيتها كان
شاب مصري يعمل كحارس لعماره قيد الانشاء
اصيب بعيارين نارين ولم يتم تحديده القاتل
حينها فسجل ضد مجهول الامن الاردني اعاده
فتح ملف القضيه ليقودهم ذلك الى معلومات
جديده حصلت الاشتباه بشخص كان يعمل في
العماره نفسها فالقي القبض عليه وبتوسع في
التحقيق اعترف بارتكابه الجريمه بعد ان
ضبطه الحارس اثناء قيامه مصر سرقه
بعد ثلاث سنوات من القيود التي اعتبرت
الاكثر الصرامه في العالم لمواجهه رائحه
كورونا فتحت الصين مؤخرا حدودها وبدا
المسافرون بتدفق عبر المعابر البريه
والبحريه من هون كونج الى البر الرئيسي
للصيني عمليات الاغلاق الواسعه في الصين
كانت الحقت اضرارا كبيره بثاني اكبر
اقتصاد في العالم فيما يامل المستثمرون في
ان تؤدي اعاده الفتح في نهايه المطاف الى
تنشيط الى الاقتصاد الذي تقدر قيمته بنحو
17 تريليون دولار ويعاني من ادنى معدل نمو
ما يقرب من نصف القرن
نختم من باريس حيث احتشد الالاف من
المتظاهرين في العاصمه الفرنسيه احتجاجا
على ارتفاع الاسعار ونظام التقاعد الذي
عرضه الرئيس الفرنسي متظاهر السترات
الصفراء نزلوا الى الشوارع مجددا بعد ان
اعلنت الحكومه الفرنسيه انها قد تعتمد
مرونه بشان خطتها لرفع سن التقاعد الى 65
عاما في اطار مشروع اصلاح نظام التقاعد
المثير للجدل والذي اثار غضبا نقاباتي
والعمال
[موسيقى]